foreign
so let's go out to James in Los Angeles
James you there
yeah how you doing John a big fan of
your show I'm I'm uh I was calm but now
that uh I hear the shows I'm kind of a
little nervous all right hey uh I don't
know what I'm doing either man so we're
all just gonna figure this one out so
I'm gonna bring on Mary right now Mary
you there
I'm here all right so James and Mary are
you on the same house
yes I'm um separate rooms okay so before
we get going this is a question I always
ask people when I'm sitting down in this
situation
um everybody's safe everybody good
everybody able to be honest
okay
and before we go one step further is
there anybody that's gonna drop any sort
of
Bombshells today
not not from my end
she's not from Miami oh Mary yes you
are okay listen Mary before you do you
gotta say hey remember when I said I
wasn't going to I'm good I'm going to
right now okay cool
no yeah no there's no bombs yes there is
I can tell okay awesome all right so uh
James you reached out y'all have been
separated for a year and a half tell me
the story
um from the beginning right
um jump into the middle
okay
um I was I was not a loving uh has been
um I was like I've been listening to
your show for a year so this helped me
tremendously tremendously I um I was
like what's up with people that you
explained one time that I could be
sitting in the couch and my kids and my
wife could feel the energy that I'm just
on top of them so it was that type of
environment uh never physical never
never like that but um uh I stopped
doing the cute things with her I wasn't
um I was when she'll try to like make
love to me I was always not confident on
myself so I would be neglect
um
did you ever cheat on her
uh yes and I barely told her last week
after watching your show I got with my
pastor because I don't have I don't have
friendships or nothing and I'm working
on that and I got help and he actually
listened to the show and then and I told
her I told him I was like I'm all in
he's like well if you're all in you have
to get out the secrets out there and
then you got to tell her so I was trying
to do it on while there was a third
party but that that a couple days before
we're gonna meet up with that Pastor to
to me tell her um she asked me because
we're hanging out since we have kids
we're trying to get a surprise a good
birthday gift for my baby she asked me
and um and I had it prepare for then I
told the test I was like hey if she
asked me before I don't want to lie to
her what I do is like you gotta be
honest and then whatever she asks you to
be honest so
um I did a cheat on her once um uh years
ago like maybe like 2019 around that
time okay and um it's been extremely
hard for me because I it's hard for me
to open up uh I don't know I never
before I didn't have the tools but
listening to you I started reaching out
to community pastors I'm barely uh
really started running therapy and
everything so it's been helping me a lot
and uh and I one of your shows said if
you don't open up right now you're gonna
open up how you really feel you're gonna
live with a life full of regret so I was
like I don't want to lose my wife I want
to open up and um I actually when I went
on my where's where we live with split
so when I had my baby
um uh I've seen some messages on his
phone uh that she took pictures of of
conversations of people she was speaking
to and then I wanted them that she
actually slept with a guy while we're
separating so that thing Hit me hard at
it but in my mind I was already ready to
tell her so I'm like oh my God I'm
really losing my wife so uh that even
with a fire behind me to actually be
like I gotta open up regardless how hard
it is so um
um so so here's what I want to say
brother
um let's put the infidelity aside let's
put all the other stuff aside
okay I want to say
um
you are in very rare air
okay
air a i r you're in very rare and if you
were right here I would get up from
where I'm at I'd pull these dumb
headphones out of my ears and I'd I'd
give you a hug okay I'm proud of you it
made me want to cry because well no no
no no here's why here's why I don't
excuse what you did we got to get
through that stuff okay and we haven't
heard Mary's side but what I do here
is a desperate man who has done a what I
think is a really hard thing
uh what's your what's your uh ethnic
background
I'm actually my Mexican okay
you're you're staring down Generations
you're staring into the future and
you're saying I want a different kind of
man in the mirror I want my kids to
experience a different kind of man I
want my wife to experience a different
kind of man and
um I want things to be different that's
a hard hard path to take and so I want
to tell you I'm proud of you that's hard
okay thank you cool
cool I really appreciate that's really
what I'm trying to I don't know that's
really my what I'm all in for okay good
for you man it's it's tough it's tough
it's tough it's tough and you're you can
be an example to millions of men
listening to this thing right now okay
all right so Mary tell me your side
um maybe so I'm just I'm just gonna say
hey uh be so great if you were like
everything he just said is full of crap
here's what really happened that'd be
awesome but but go ahead
so
I guess a little backstory is that we
were a blended family so I came with
kids he has boys um and we have together
one little one which is six years old
how many in total um so five all
together okay are you still in contact
with their dad
um no so I was I'm a single mom to my
first two my oldest okay
um so
I mean there was obviously I'm not going
to say everything was bad
um but a lot of the things you know his
attitude like the way he was towards us
it was just you know it made the whole
relationship a little hard
um can we say can we say can we say it
made the whole thing real hard
yeah okay let's don't minimize it okay
it was hard it was tough yeah it was
hard um you were you were a single mom
with now five kids and
kind of a gigantic toddler with an
attitude problem right and I had it yes
and I had come from a domestic violence
relationship with my first relationship
so
um when I got pregnant right away I went
into the relationship with James and
I was five months pregnant when my mom
passed away she got killed by a drunk
driver
so apart from my relationship that was
another big thing that took a toll on me
um and then so I left because obviously
his attitude the way it was going and
then uh you know messages here and there
that I found of him talking to other
other women you know um and things I
would say please don't do this please
don't do that and he just he didn't care
um so I split from him and like you said
it's been a year and a half and I feel
like I'm finally at a place where I'm at
peace like I'm really happy I'm I'm at a
place where I'm I feel good
um and
when he saw obviously he said those
messages and he and I asked questions
and he confessed to me that just opened
a whole other
I guess pain in my heart because
pain and Clarity because now I can look
back and say now it makes sense now you
weren't Christmas that's why right that
was a big one because I really thought
the whole relationship was like what am
I doing wrong like why you know maybe I
am crazy because he would throw those
comments you're crazy you're crazy like
what are you talking about you know and
now it's like okay it makes sense and
that's that's kind of where I'm at right
now and so
is this phone call are y'all are you
interested in getting back together too
or are you are you
you're obviously going to be in a
relationship with James for a long time
because you'll have a kid together
um are you interested in in
um just having a like a good grown-up
adult friendship with somebody that you
share a child with but you want to move
on with your life because I hear from
James
I mean James you said I don't want to
lose my wife and I realize oh man she's
she is seeking out
um physical and emotional connection
with other men can add on to it please
yeah of course of course when we first
met uh I met her uh my job at warehouse
um so to me it was like love at first
sight like physically at least you know
like and then when I met her I was like
oh my gosh she's a Christian like I
always wanted a Christian woman anyways
um so after a meeting era the guy that
introduced us I ended up hearing rumor
that that she slept with him so I end up
confronting her I found this out after
like everybody found out that she was
pregnant that confessed her she's like
yeah like a month or two before so that
and then there's another guy that always
chase after her and she confessed that
she said with him too and then at church
she confessed I was like is there
anything else when she she confess one
more person so like coming in I was
already feeling uh like that so I feel
like I'm in the same boat right now
since I've seen those messages because
I'm like she's she's I'm starting the
same way as we started like she she she
came with sleeping with men like right
before so I was like hold on hold on I I
don't think it's fair to hold her
accountable for things that she did
before y'all were together
uh
okay well here's all I'm saying you knew
those things
and you opted in
true and you knew those things and you
opted in and then you had a baby
together then y'all got married right
and so I also think and
you came in admittedly feeling less than
you already walked in the front door
carrying her Across the Threshold
comparing yourself to at least those
three guys
okay for sure so it's important that you
own both of it I opted into this deal so
I'm not gonna opt in and then just sit
there and complain about what I opted in
for okay and
you own your side which is man I
instantly felt comparison less than like
whoa like I I and most men feel that and
most men spend their lives puffing their
chest Out Swinging
um running from stuff numbing out or
blaming people and so for you to look in
the mirror and say no no I gotta own
that I felt less than that's a big huge
step okay
okay is that fair
yes thank you for that and then this
comes so
um Mary where are you are you interested
in getting back with James
um to be honest I don't have them okay
um
I I don't want to say okay because to be
honest this in December I filed for
divorce okay
um and like I would say a month after
almost two was when he found the
messages and he came to me you know
saying hey let's work this out you know
and I was already you know out and now
I'm kind of like
I I feel like I could eventually maybe
give this another try
but I don't want to just jump back in
and say yeah I'm all in I think for him
it's easier to say I'm all in because he
was the one that messed up you know um I
I feel like I like I like I told him I'm
in a really good place right now and I
said I need if there is any ever ever a
chance again I said I need you to work
on yourself because
I know a lot of the the things he did to
me uh you know a lot of his attitude and
everything I know it comes from like
trauma that he's had in his childhood or
things in his past and I told him I need
you to work on yourself because I'm
doing the same and I know I'm not
perfect obviously I I'm actually seeking
therapy right now
um because I've been through so many
things and it's like we can't you know
we both can't come to try and build a
healthy home happy home if we're not
healed ourselves enough absolutely all
right can I have two other two of course
you can
um since I've been listening to your
show I'm literally like every day for a
year I've been forcing myself I'll grow
up uh single child since I was 12. I
have no memories uh sitting down in the
kitchen table my family the same parents
uh one brother told you like 11 years
apart no memories at all I got racial
babysitter so left home alone so I
always felt like in need of like love
now it's not as bad but I've been
seeking Health Therapy since a year two
uh your therapy barely maybe like two
weeks ago but but like actually like
getting to me with the pastors and he's
a counselor and all that for years so
I've been like letting myself uh as a
person I need a lot of work obviously
but um that's my question too for you is
she's at her best I've ever seen and I'm
happy because she's done a great job and
and to me I want my family back so it's
like if she does give me a try I wanna I
wanna I wanna bring I want to lift her
up I want to be something
uh I I I want you know what I'm saying
something I got you I got you
um all right so I'm gonna I'm gonna talk
to YouTube but I'm also gonna use this
as an opportunity to talk to a broader
audience
the last number I heard was 50 percent
50 of couples coming into some sort of
marriage counseling or dealing with
infidelity
okay and so I tell you all that to not
make it an excuse but to let you know
that um y'all aren't by yourself in this
deal okay
and it's very common for one person to
be out I'm done
or I like the healing that's happening
in my life right now and let me give
give you some different language maybe
For the First Time Mary in a long time
you feel safe your body feels at peace
right like your shoulders drop when you
walk into your apartment or into your
house
you're not worried about whether you're
gonna get hit you're not worried about
whether there's going to be a
radioactive guy on the couch whether
you're gonna get bombarded with five
different kids like so your body feels
safe and James
for the first time in a long time you're
making connections that probably men in
your in your family line have never made
which is for sure I have a body that is
starved for connection the worst the way
to torture James is to withhold love
because that happened your whole life
right
very perfectly safe and so as a that's a
you can see how really quick we can get
into a pretty unhealthy dance where you
are almost demanding connection which
then and of itself isn't connection and
Mary has had people Force connection on
her for a long time and so her body
pulls away which then makes the alarms
and your body get louder and you get
closer and get more radioactive and she
almost will connect with you out of
Defense right so here's what we have to
do
you have to own that what you had
together is over now okay let's put a
period at the end of it James you're
gonna drive yourself mad
trying to get back quote unquote what
you had
you're right I was I'm driving myself
crazy yeah you you drive yourself crazy
and Mary doesn't want what she had she
likes her life now and she's got peace
finally
okay and so what we want to do and by
the way this is going to be helpful for
you too whether you just stay really
good friends who are great co-parents
with your kids and your kids by the way
deserve that okay yeah
um
what you have to work on moving forward
is we've got to create something
completely new
something where that probably neither of
you saw in your parents lives
that you probably all have never
experienced together which means we're
going to have to give each other a lot
of Grace
we're gonna have to get rid of the
victim mentality and the perpetrator
mentality we're both here okay
all right we're both together and now
what we're going to do is here's where
the healing is going to begin you both
know what you're capable of
you both know that you can lie to each
other that you can hide from each other
that you can tell each you all both know
that you both know you can keep deep
secrets from one another right
yes you both know that you can look each
other and say I'm in Forever are you in
forever I'm in forever and both of y'all
weren't in forever right so here's the
thing you both know that about each
other many many people never find the
depths of what they're capable of y'all
have
and what I would tell you and this is
going to sound crazy that is a powerful
place to start rebuilt rebuilding
something new from
that there's some deep intimacy shared
there I know what I'm capable of and you
know what you're capable of
let's sit down at the table here okay
and here's what it's gonna look like
moving forward
you all got to come up with a language a
way that you talk to one another where
Mary is allowed to say
um no thank you
and James you're gonna have to feel that
in your body not as a rejection but as
Mary
standing up and letting her needs be
heard
because your body's gonna scream
rejection rejection rejection fight run
and you're gonna have to just simply say
no that's another adult that I love and
care about who loves and cares about me
who just doesn't want to go get coffee
tonight
yeah that's what I said I've been doing
that like my best uh like not take it as
rejection like you said my body reacts
to it good good good good now if you
James do a bunch of stuff if you change
a bunch of things in your life to quote
unquote get her back
that is that's a that's jet fuel and
it's Rocket Fuel inside of a a missile
it runs out it burns real hot and goes
real fast and it goes it burns out real
quick
yes you are gonna have to look in the
mirror and decide I'm worth being
healthy and well for James
yes and my promise is when you are
healthy and well for James which means
I'm going to keep talking to somebody
that I trust who's got experience in
training so I can get some of these
lessons I didn't learn at home growing
up I'm going to get a group of guys that
um not that we go you know run the town
with but that we hang out we do fun
stuff we watch the fights we we take
trips together we whatever we do right
we do life together we fix each other's
cars together whatever it is
and then you're gonna present to marry a
body that is not desperately trying to
use her to feel safe which in turn is
going to let her feel safe see what I'm
saying I understand it's hard
it's hard it is because I'm trying to
I'm trying to see how
um how to take away that oh I want to do
it for her as well but I want to like do
it for you to learn how to like do it
for me yes do it for you no one's ever
told you this man but you're worth it
thank you and I'm not saying that just
play Kate and if I was here I'd make it
really awkward I'd put my hands on on
either side of your face and I'd scare
you directly into your eyes okay I'd
make it real real weird man
but listen you're worth that and Mary
you're worth being safe and you're worth
feeling at peace
yeah right so this is the launching pad
for what comes next Mary you're gonna
have to commit to being honest with him
and not lobbing grenades and can we be
honest you could throw some grenades
can't you you know how to hurt James
right
yeah I do you've never done that before
have you
yes you have yes you have
and James
you're gonna have to commit to getting
well for you
yes sir and then you're able to show up
with Mary now let's let's not walk away
here with any like rose-colored glasses
she said right now I'm not interested in
a romantic relationship with James James
I want you to hear that that's hard to
hear okay it is you said you said the
words I don't want to lose my wife she's
telling you
I'm I've stepped out okay and so we're
not trying to get back what was we're
trying to build something completely new
Mary or are you do you feel unsafe going
to coffee
no I don't um we actually tried dinner a
couple days ago and like I told him I
said we can be
can be let's try something let's be
friends let's get to know each other
again and that's you know see if any
this can go anywhere you know and James
I think that's a really wise Place
starting with not
hey how do we uh how do I get you how do
I get you back how do we get let's just
instead of starting there I think we
start with hey my name is James
and uh I have a couple of kids and I
have this woman that I'm madly in love
with that I man one time I I screwed it
up you want to hear that story
and she can say hi my name is Mary and
I've been through a lot
and uh
I'd love to meet you I'd love to get to
know you a little bit better let's start
there
it's gonna be hard to take the pressure
off because you all do have history
together you got life together but let's
start there
let's start communicating with our big
friends let's start connecting I don't
even say starting to woo or date but I
don't even know if Mary if you're there
yet if you're not that's great you get
to have that choice
and James here's a hard hard thing last
hard thing
this one may be done
and let's get to the worst case scenario
this if if this is done your
relationship with Mary is over your
friendship's not your co-parenting is
not but you're you're dating
relationship your romantic relationship
with Mary's over
you're still worth a peaceful life
you're still worth being well
and you're still worthy of being loved
continue the journey you started my
brother I'm proud of you Mary continue
honoring your body and your own safety
and man
I can't wait to hear what happens next
with you two so keep me in the loop I'm
grateful for you all for calling and
sharing your story
um and from this point forward
we never cheat again right good